it really was like a dream
better than a dream you love what you
did see but ever wonder what you didn't
get to watch deleted scenes are
guaranteed to exist for just about every
movie you have ever watched some are no
more than a few seconds long while
others span minutes and give a whole new
meaning to the movie the cutting room
floor is a place full with what could
have been what disney live action films
would have a completely different tone
with their deleted scenes and what
original songs did you never get to hear
and get your dried-up desiccated little
brain working the baroness is not one
for sympathy as she demonstrated
throughout cruella there's a deleted
scene where the baroness is reviewing
her employees designs including
cruella's she takes and crumples up one
employee's design and also interrupts
cruella to take her design but she
doesn't crumple it up instead pinning it
to the board in the back
i need more this scene shows how
talented cruella is as a designer
gaining some approval from the cold
baroness
the queen is a master manipulator and
the scene where she tells aurora that
maleficent is at fault for what happened
the night before at dinner is a perfect
example of that this scene has an
extended version that shows more of that
manipulation it has the queen announcing
to philip and aurora the wedding will
take place in three days time
there is a deleted scene in cinderella
that would have added a lot to the
character of ella the scene in question
has ella taking the initiative to write
a letter to kit
dearest mr kit
or should i say your royal highness but
it falls into the hands of the grand
duke who doesn't deliver the letter to
him ella waits for kit not knowing that
the letter has been intercepted this
scene shows ella's bravery and how she
was willing to take action should she as
an empowered and strong young woman in
love make an approach to the prince
herself
ella's friend and partner in crime horus
had more lines than we saw on screen he
improvised a lot of funny lines on set
well he was hoping there's a plane c why
was plan c but they didn't quite fit the
tone of the scenes they were in director
craig gillespie loved actor paul
hauser's energy but had to do what was
best for the film it was about how much
we wanted to keep the gravity of what's
going on versus having these
punctuations of humor sounds like hauser
had a great time playing horus in french
that is unfappion
at the beginning of the movie cinderella
ella's father gives her a box that opens
into a flower with a butterfly on a
stick inside young ella is fascinated by
the gift in a deleted scene ella's
stepmother sells her late husband's
clothing and belongings including this
flower box ella sees this happen and
retrieves the box smiling as she plays
with the butterfly and remembers her
father
i'm not done with you yet
me neither after the townspeople toss
bell's clothes on the ground there is a
deleted scene where gaston disperses the
crowd and attempts to court bell it
shows gaston's influence over the people
as they don't question him and obey his
orders a bit of foreshadowing for when
they follow him later to attack the
beast when we previewed the movie there
were people in the audience who got
confused there is an entire scene in
beauty and the beast that had to be cut
and re-shot because of a mistake
director bill condon made the scene
showed the beast's mother singing to him
in bed as a child and was juxtaposed
with another scene of the prince looking
down at his mother on her deathbed
unfortunately viewers at the early
screenings were confused and thought the
prince's mother was the enchantress
scene at the beginning of the film the
two actresses do look very similar after
all the scene was reshot and audiences
were none the wiser of the change the
screen is set up on either side of us so
that we can kind of
uh create an ambiance did you know an
entire song was cut from aladdin it was
a duet between aladdin and princess
jasmine it's sung after they first meet
and then are separated it's a lovely
tune that highlights both characters
desire to find something more in their
lives luckily disney released the song
online so us fans could enjoy it when
ella horus and jasper are robbing hotel
guests towards the beginning of the
movie they are caught by the hotel
assistant manager and run away however
there is an extended version of this
scene that was cut instead of running
ella swindles the man out of some money
frederick
before the hotel guest comes out of his
room and calls them out it's a fun
little scene that shows how convincing
ella can be
there was a nice moment between prince
philip and aurora that was cut from
maleficent mistress of evil the scene
showed the two dancing while the queen
looked on and judged commanding them to
do the dance again it's another great
example of the queen's manipulation and
her attempt to turn aurora into a
version of herself
she still won't take my hand
you may have found it odd that mulan and
her love interest hung way never shared
a kiss in the live-action adaptation the
movie did originally have a kiss scene
between the two characters but the scene
was removed the reason was because
chinese audiences found the kiss to be
inappropriate it was very beautiful but
the chinese office went no you can't
that doesn't feel right to the chinese
people so we took it out the town's
people versus the castle is one of the
most fun scenes in the live-action
beauty and the beast and contains a lot
of small moments between characters
however not all these moments made it
into the movie they cut a scene where
lumiere tortures lefou after he captures
feather duster in a net this is a
recreation of a classic scene in the
original film where lumiere does the
same exact thing
so
what are you gonna do now
brush my teeth
another moment that was cut from the
castle battle scene was a moment where
lefou backs through a door to escape the
battle he finds that he is in a bathroom
and there is a toilet in there that
drenches him with water this character's
name was mazur toilette and his human
version played by steven merchant
reunited with lefou at the end of the
film director bill condon considered the
humor low brow compared to the rest of
the scene so it was cut the emperor's
eject
one male from every family
is that what you are one scene that was
cut from mulan showed more of the
relationship between hawk and mulan hawk
is struck by lightning and lands in the
forest trees mulan finds her and helps
her down they have a conversation about
not hiding who they are which we can see
resonates with mulan this scene helps
support why hawk would be willing to
sacrifice herself for mulan towards the
end of the film
will smith's genie has a lot of fun
moments but he had even more that were
left on the cutting room floor there's
an extended version of the scene where
the genie is warning aladdin about being
very careful about how he phrases his
wishes be clear
be specific with your words
in the deleted footage we see a guy who
wishes to be irresistible to women
someone who wishes to hold the universe
in his hands and another guy who wishes
that everything he touches turns to gold
and it doesn't end well an alternate
scene at the beginning of alice through
the looking glass shows alice following
absalom through the dining hall where
hamish spots the butterfly and crushes
him alice sees this and responds by
tackling hamish to the ground and
beating him
we ended up cutting it because for many
people i think it made out as too crazy
we would have to agree
i'll meet you when you're younger and
i'm older
i realize it doesn't make much sense
there is a small scene between the mad
hatter and alice that was removed from
through the looking glass when alice
travels back in time and finds the
hatter in his village they take a walk
and the hatter makes alice a hat it's a
small moment but demonstrates the
kindness the mad hatter shows towards a
stranger surprise
there's a deleted scene where prince
anders gifts princess jasmine and her
family a giant cannon they are not
impressed with the gift as jasmine
explains how they are more interested in
the sentiment behind a gift not the size
or price it's a simple scene that
demonstrates how jasmine is not a
material person and how aladdin is the
perfect match for her there's a deleted
scene that shows mulan falling into
water and getting rescued by the phoenix
it's a cool looking scene that shows
more of mulan's guardian doing exactly
what it was sent to do what were you
doing
that
i was about to charge the enemy
a deleted scene in cinderella shows a
conversation between the prince and ella
they discuss heaven and if their mothers
know each other there it's a very
optimistic scene that shows the two
forming a strong bond
i think heaven is
it's like the palace ball
everyone's invited those scenes surely
gave a whole new look to their movies
while it's disappointing to see what
could have been we know that the
creators made the tough decision to cut
these scenes for the benefit of the film
still it's fun to imagine a whole new
version of our favorite disney movies
with these scenes included which scene
would you have liked to see stay in the
movie